تنضم الينا من عمان جهان بسيسو نائبه
المدير العام لاطباء بلا حدود في بروكسل
سيده جيهان بالاضافه الى القيود المفروضه
والتي استمعنا اليها على سيارات الاسعاف
هنالك ايضا استهداف لهذه السيارات هذا
الاستهداف يتكرر اعتقال لفرق الاسعاف كيف
تصفون
ذلك نحن كاطباء بلا حدود نرصد ونشهد
استهداف
المستشفيات العيادات الطواقم الطبيه
سيارات الاسعاف لقد فقدنا اربع من زملائنا
منذ بدء الحرب اللي ما زالت في اكثر من 80
يوم وما زلنا نطالب بوقف اطلاق نار فوري
ومستدام لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه العمل الطبي في وقت الحرب صعب جدا
وعمل طبي انساني بتحت قصف مستمر وقنابل لا
تتوقف
شبه مستحيل الوضع اكثر من ماساوي اكثر من
من كارثه ومفروض
ضمان سلام وحمايه الطواقم الطبيه المشافي
اللي هي اصلا بطلت تشتغل كمستشفيات صارت
المستشفيات والمباني الطبيه ملاجئ لالاف
العائلات النازحين اللي عم بدنهم ينزحوا
مش مره مش مرتين ثلاث مرات واربع
مرات ما كان في هدنه قصيره وهشه شفنا لاول
مره
بعيادات والاماكن اللي تعمل فيها اطباء
بلا حدود منهم مستشفى الاقصى في في وسط
القطاع ومستشفى ناصر في جنوب القطاع
وعياده اوليه ايضا للصحه الاوليه قريبه من
منطقه المواسي شفنا لاول مره مرضى مش جرحه
حرب وهذا بدل انه الاحتياجات الطبيه هائله
الوضع كثير صعب حاليا طيب سيده جهان يعني
كل ما ذكرتي هو مكفول بالقانون الدولي
الانساني ذكرتي ايضا بان هنالك من اصدقاء
لكم ومن عناصر الصليب او اطباء بلا حدود
تم استهدافهم بشكل مباشر طيب اليوم ما هي
الاليات التي يتم اعتمادها من اجل حمايه
الطواقم التابعه لكم وهل هي هذه الاليات
كانت دائما يتم التبليغ عن وجود طواقم هل
يتم تبليغ الجانب الاسرائيلي عن وجود هذه
الطواقم في اماكن
محدده القانون الدولي الانساني
2286 مفروض يحمي المنشات الطبيه في وقت
الحرب واللي عم نشوفه بغزه عكس ذلك اماكن
المشافي معروف اماكن المستشفيات والعيادات
معروف وما يزل وما
يزال ما تزال مستهدفه
باستمرار بنعرف عن حالات صعبه كان
كثير مستحيل توصلوها سيارات
الاسعاف
انه سيدات الحوامل عم تولد بالشارع بدل ما
تكون بالمستشفيات عشان المستشفيات
والعيادات صارت مرات اخطر اخطر من من خيم
النزوح و ومدارس الان اللي ايضا كمان تقصف
هناك اليات مثل القانون الدولي الانساني
اللي المفروض يحمي هذا العمل وقت الحرب
لكن ما نراه عكس ذلك وعشان هيك نحن كاطباء
بلا حدود حتى قرار مجلس الامن الدولي
بعتبره ناقص لانه عم بكد على شيء كثير مهم
اللي هو التدفق السريع للمساعدات
ولكن التدفق لمساعدات وتوزيع المساعدات
شبه مستحيل طالما في قصف وطالما في قنابل
وتتساقط على على المدنيين الفلسطينين بغزه
وطالما في نزوح جماعي وكل هذا بيمنع
الوصول ل المنشات طبيه كل الطواقم الطبيه
بتحتاج ممرات امنه بتحتاج معايير بسيطه
جدا ولكن من غير
ها الحدود الامنيه والمعاير الامنيه
مستحيل عمل الاطباء مستحيل الان هنالك
ازمه اضافيه الجثث المتحلله الموجوده في
الشوارع والمنتشره في الشوارع اي تداعيات
لذلك على الوضع الصحي المتردي اساسا كما
ذكرتي
اكيد طبعا عدم دفن الجثث هو
يعتبر ازمه صحيه وهذا يعتبر مشكله كبيره
جدا هناك ايضا تصلنا حالات
عدوى امراض متناقل بسبب
ايضا فصل الشتاء
ومرضى اللي عندهم امراض مزمنه اللي ما عم
روحوا على على على العيادات ولا على
المشافي وع بيكون طبعا اكيد في نقص
بالدواء والاساسيات ف اي يعني برجع لموضوع
استهداف المستشفيات وال وال والعيادات نحن
كاطباء بلا حدود لا نستطيع معالجه الجثث
الهامده اي يعني عم ووصلنا عدد هائل جدا
من القتلى على في المشاف اللي بنشتغل فيها
مثل عدد الجرحى وفي يوم معين من اكم اسبوع
كان عدد القتلى اللي وصلنا اكثر من عدد
الجرحى هذا الرقم لحاله
بيوصف الموقف وصلنا 165 قتيل هذاك اليوم
اكثر من الجرحه فمستحيل نعمل بهذه الظروف
وهناك كوادر فلسطينيه واحنن عندنا طاقم
صغير دولي بيعمل جنب طاقم فلسطيني منهك
على الاخر
وبحتاج اقل
مقادير الامن والامان عشان يقدر يكمل شغله
شكرا لك سيده جيهان بسيسو نائبه المدير
العام لاطباء بلا حدود في brel